as you know earth is divided into time
zones but when did the idea of the time
zone come about and when was the current
day formalized system of time zones
created so first of all people have
known for a very long time that the
world is round and thus that it was day
time on different parts of earth at
different times the thing is for the
overwhelming majority of human history
it was completely irrelevant because
when you were traveling by foot by ship
or by horse who would move too slowly to
notice the difference so when did time
zones become a broader concept that
mattered to the average person well it
happened around the mid 19th century and
was down to two major technological
advancements the first being the
railways because it was considered
somewhat important not to have two
trains on the same track at the same
time and the second was the Telegraph so
the first country to introduce a time
zone was the United Kingdom this
happened in 1847 when railway operators
switched from the numerous local times
which were often several minutes off of
each other to Greenwich Mean Time
this was regulated by the Greenwich
Observatory who had a permanent
Telegraph link to the railway stations
across the country would update them
with accurate times to set the clocks to
now just because the railways adopted
these measures didn't mean the rest of
the country did and the process of
creating a unified time for the nation
took many decades and in fact the
primary pusher for this wasn't business
but workers unions and their
parliamentary representatives there was
a fairly common practice a factory
owners buying clocks that intentionally
ran slow during the day so that the
workers would work ten and a half hours
whilst only believing they work ten and
another reason was the desire to control
when alcohol could be sold in order to
legislate for both of these time had to
be standardised a process completed with
the 1880 definition of time act which
split the United Kingdom into two time
zones Greenwich Mean Time and Dublin
Mean Time which was 25 minutes behind
the same process happened shortly
afterwards in the United States which
itself adopted what's called Standard
Time in 1883 this was the result of
discussions between American and
Canadian railroad tycoons who had
collectively decided to split
continental North America into five time
zones later reduced to four these time
zones were wildly different to the ones
used today and also the American
government and public weren't consulted
in the end there was a much the US
government could do about it and so in
1918 it made it official and passed it
into law so what about globally well
after the
adopted standard time in 1883 president
Chester Arthur called for a convention
to standardize time across international
borders they saw delegations from the
world's great powers and also Liberia
who discussed which country would be
home to the universal time and the
country selected was the United Kingdom
much to the annoyance of the French
delegation who refused to accept this
change and continue to use their own
parish time until 1911 when they
reluctantly signed up to the
international standard and thus the
international system of standardized
time zones was created and over the next
century the world's nations signed up to
it the last one being Liberia despite
having agreed to it nearly a century
prior I hope you enjoyed this episode
and a special thanks to all my patreon
supporters James vis annette marvin
castle a man of culture kelly moneymaker
danny Meloni Jon biscuit Rob Waterhouse
Moe Aaron the white James Castaneda
Gustav Swan Jordan long ray
Marcus Ozma spinning three plates
cooling Castleman filled oink oink
Rashid Ali David Silverman
easy Maggie packs Kowski Spencer
Lightfoot of Winston K word Robert
Wetzel Lexy Schwinn Anthony Beckett and
Skye Chappell 90 years Liberia get it
together